avant de commencer l'information de
l'après midi c'est le rejet par la
commission de la candidature de sylvie
goulard à la commission européenne elle
a été recalée par une large majorité des
députés européens 82 voix contre 29
candidate proposé par emmanuel macron
elle devait reprendre un très important
portefeuille qui comprenait le marché
intérieur l'industrie la défense
l'espace le numérique et la culture mais
les eurodéputés s'étaient interrogés sur
les affaires qui la concerne à savoir
les emplois fictifs du modem et puis
cette rémunération d'un gros think tank
germano-américain quand elle était
heureux pki eurodéputés de 2013 à 2016
des sommes en jeu de 300 mille dollars
l'elysée dénonce un jeu politique qui
touche la commission européenne dans son
ensemble
agathe kg une réaction qu'est ce que
vous en pensez je pense que ça touche
d'avoir l'image de la france l'image de
la france comme moteur de l'union
européenne
on peut être d'accord ou pas avec le
choix de proposer sirigu leur part
emmanuel macron le rejet est un roger
qui fait mal et qui affaiblit notre pays
on sait que l'europe est politique on
sait qu'il ya des jeux politiques sans
doute était ce c'était un choix
compliqué qu'on peut interroger de
proposer une candidate qu'on avait soi
même sorti du gouvernement à cause de
mise en examen alors certes il n'ya
peut-être pas la même jurisprudence
entre la commission européenne et la
jurisprudence française mais si on ne
naît pas si on peut pas être ministre en
france est ce qu'on peut vraiment être
commissaire européen on peut comprendre
la réaction des parlementaires européens
leur choix c'était notamment l'argument
et françois-xavier bel ami mathieu
st-pierre est ce que c'est un camouflet
pour maquereau ou bien ce sont des
affaires politiques qui concerne la
commission toute entière et je sais pas
si c'est un camouflet en tout cas c'est
une déconvenue évidemment ils avaient
plutôt bien tiré son épingle du jeu en
oeuvre en justement a en particulier à
la désignation de la patronne de la
commission européenne à l'époque tout le
monde avait considéré qu'il avait
vrai de façon plutôt habile en lien avec
angela merkel sont qu'à l'époque il
était sorti plutôt auréolé de cet
activisme et là évidemment c'est
l'arroseur arrosé en tout cas un effet
boomerang contestable le mans est ce que
c'est un bon choix selon vous daniel
bilalian visiblement non c'est simple
pour moi quelqu'un qui n'a pas pu être
ministre en france on le propose pour
être avoir une responsabilité européenne
enfin je sais pas mais qu'est ce que je
peux dire d'autre c'est impensable et
puis alors la manière dont il réagit le
président un public assez en disant
faudra qu'on m'explique
ouais attendez il ya des moments il ya
des mamans moi je ne sais plus je ne
sais plus quoi dire sait plus quoi dire
marie visot alors est ce que c'est une
vengeance de la commission qui n'a pas
apprécié le coup de force contre le le
système des personnes candidates ou bien
est-ce que c'était juste un mauvais
choix ouais c'est sûr et c'est vrai que
c'est la défense comme de la france
qu'on commence à entendre du côté de
l'elysée aujourd'hui
bon effectivement comme vous le disiez
il ya des jeux politiques on le sait ce
qui est dommage c'est qu'on en voit se
faire canarder une femme qui était au
delà de ce que tout ce que vous avez dit
qui est très juste qui était très
compétente pour ce portefeuille assez
important que la france avait avait
réussi à obtenir
donc tout ça est un peu dommage bon
suivante associés qu'on va suivre avec
attention et on suivra les prochains
quand